c'est le nouveau rêve américain plus
nous avons accès à deux choses plus vite nous les
voulons je joue Richie le premier gars qui
se fait prendre dans le monde du
jeu en ligne vous avez une école à payer je
possède 60 mille frais de scolarité dus la semaine prochaine
bienvenue au  de l'argent du monde réel et
découvre qu'il existe un algorithme qui
triche vous vous attendez à ce que je vous rende tout
cet argent c'est ma dernière chance
et au lieu de dénoncer je l'apporte
au propriétaire au Costa Rica j'ai été
trompé sur votre site noir de minuit
aurait pu aller sur les forums Internet vous l'a
apporté c'est un
bloc mondial au rythme effréné voit quelqu'un avec qui il se
rapporte enfin a tout intérêt
à tenter sa chance dans de vraies affaires au fur et à mesure que le
film progresse, il devient ce genre de
rôle d'apprenti mentor oh mon dieu
plus il entre dans l'histoire
, plus il devient riche, plus il a un gars dans le
mauvais monde qui essaie de tout faire de la
bonne façon.
ing miroirs vous allez
nous obtenir la preuve sur bloqué si vous
ne le faites pas
cela devient un vrai thriller complet c'est la
vie ou la mort